[Music]
over the past decade john logan has
become one of hollywood's most prolific
screenwriters
his films range from epics like
gladiator and the last samurai to star
trek nemesis the aviator any given
sunday and sweeney todd in the past
couple of years he has written animated
comedy rango adapted shakespeare's
correlanus and worked with martin
scorsese again on 3d period adventure
hugo
he has proved to be perhaps the most
versatile of contemporary screenwriters
and it is this variety in logan's work
that continues to dazzle
by the time i wrote my first screenplay
i mean i'd been a starving playwright
for 10 years in chicago and i mean
starving and i mean 10 years and you
know my job was shelving books in a
library and i did it for 10 years and i
wrote plays and i worked with starving
directors and starving actors and
starving theaters at closing the night
you know to learn how to be a dramatist
if you want to be a screenwriter a
successful screenwriter here's the
secret here it is i'm going to tell you
this is what you have to do it's great
don't tell anyone you have to read
hamlet
and you have to read it again and you
have to read it again and you have to
read it until you understand every word
and then you move on to king lear and
then maybe you treat yourself to troilus
and cresta and then you know what then
you're going to go back and read
aristotle's poetics until you can quote
it and then you read sophocles and you
read ibsen and then you're going to read
tony kushner and then you're going to
read checkup you're going to understand
the continuum of what it is to be a
dramatist then if you choose watch a
couple movies
but the great mastery of being a
dramatist of writing words for
characters will be taught to you by
those people who invented the form over
centuries my favorite sort of anecdote
about screenwriters uh came to me from
the writers of man on the moon and
people versus larry flint and straight
out film school they sold their first
script and their agent called him up and
said i've got good news and i got bad
news the good news is i've sold the
script for you know x hundred thousand
dollars the bad news is you're fired
and that's kind of you know indicative
of of hollywood really is that right
it's just this conveyor belt of writers
and they're happy to just kind of fire
one after another after another just to
get the script
in enough shape that they can shoot the
movie there is a notion
that what cinema is is pictures you know
and it's beautiful moving pictures and
it's a sweep and nuance of visual
storytelling it certainly is that
but it is also language it is also
characters expressing themselves through
dialogue and dialogue has become so
devalued uh in movies
which is why when when someone asked me
what do you want you realize i said i
want speeches i want language i want
tripping language i want nuance i want
kate hepburn synapses firing so quickly
you can't keep up
like i learned from pinter you know
so what i say to young writers is
read your shakespeare you know read your
shelly read your keats read your byron
love language
[Music]
when i was starting out and i didn't
know what a slug was or interior meant
or fade to meant or how you organize the
words on a page of a screenplay people
talk to me you know elder statesmen talk
to me and were and were and shepherded
me through the process my first
screenplay any given sunday which i
co-wrote with oliver stone
i hadn't written anything
and he took the time to teach me how it
worked we we did 26 drafts of any given
sunday one after another so i learned
everything about the form from him he
read it he was patient you know i'd go
to his house he'd say pick up the oscar
hold it it'll feel good you'll enjoy it
you know
and then we'd work and and any given
sunday like all these monstrous big
movies are are it was hard to get made
these are these are behemoths they're
like it's like you know the queen mary
doesn't tack quickly you know with
coriolenus which we made for nothing we
could make quick adjustments these
things are huge beasts and it's and
they're very hard to get made and it
takes a lot of work so in that case i
was not only doing the necessary work of
the screenwriter i was learning what the
necessary work for screenwriter was i'll
tell you this in any fight
it's the guy who's willing to die
who's gonna win that itch
and i know if i'm gonna have any life
anymore
it's because i'm still willing to fight
and die for that itch
because that's what living is
there's six inches in front of your face
now i can't make you do it
you gotta look at the guy next to you
look into his eyes
now i think you're gonna see a guy
who will go that inch with you hell yeah
you're going to see a guy
who will sacrifice himself for this team
because he knows when it comes down to
it you're going to do the same for him
that's a team gentlemen
and
either we heal
now
as a team
or we will die
as individuals
[Music]
that's football guys
that's all it is
i had to learn sort of the visual
metaphor of film because so much of film
is visual uh and you know cinemas
pictures and moving pictures so for me
it was learning the balance between
dialogue dialogue scenes and visual
action and how
those segway back and forth and trying
to reduce the dissonance between them so
it seemed one uh one one whole unit i'd
like to talk about what it is you do
in terms of do you write on a computer
do you write in longhand when do you
write um you know do you do outlines do
your treatments take me through the
process and what's an you know what's an
average day for you writing the the
typical day is like i i personally get
it very early i get about four um
because i found sort of the hush of
silence and darkness very conducive to
me writing um because the phone's not
ringing there's no distraction just it's
just me and and the
sort of whimsical little characters
moving about um so so i i start very
early i write until i'm tired and then i
stop and if i'm writing a first draft um
it's it's total immersion i don't do
anything else and i can work for 12
hours of stretch take a break go back
and work because my methodology
is always do the research first as much
as it takes and for something like
i mean the most research i ever did was
probably the aviator well i developed
that with with michael mann for years
and we discussed it and i did outlines i
did research and we discussed who howard
hughes is what the shape of the movie is
how much of his life to you know while i
was doing the research um it was a daily
uh you know a daily engagement with a
filmmaker
and sometimes that's the case but at any
point i sit down to write it i just seal
myself away and i just write and i can
write anywhere as long as i'm facing a
blank wall i can write in hotel rooms i
can write in la i can write new york i
write london makes no difference because
once i start i'm just sort of committed
to it and my my objects is right as
quickly the entire entire thing as
quickly as possible it's always very
ugly but but i just like to get from
beginning to end um and every day i
convince myself i'm writing king lear i
convinced it's the greatest screenplay
ever the greatest thing that's ever been
written in anything you know uh and and
at the end of that time i go back and i
work you know and i do the actual work
the actual revising because writing is
easy it's the rewriting we have to
really go and put a clinical analysis to
your work that's that's uh grinding
then when i feel the entire piece is
done to a shape that i feel
is at least respectable and i'm not
totally embarrassing myself and will
lose my entire career based on this one
awful draft i'll give it to my my
collaborators and then
it becomes public property and it and
it's always the most poignant part of
the process for me is is is sort of when
you open the door and let people into
the room before the first draft do you
outline do you treatment i mean i do i
do i outline i do i do sort of like
three or four page outlines with
sometimes just bullet points of like um
you know
sweeney todd kills judge turpin you know
or it could be longer it could be a
description of some images if if i'm
working with a director for example who
who is who's very good on images you
know developing the aviator with michael
mann there were certain images that
would come out he just loved the visual
studio i would make notes on those so
i'd remember to include them or at least
play around with those you know with
those those aspects but yeah i usually
have an outline i work on a computer
it's it's very i work in my bathroom
it's very very quiet and really terrible
and interesting there's a huge amount of
information in john logan's script i
read a few of them in preparation for
the lecture and
every kind of
he tends to put camera moves
if somebody walks away if somebody looks
sad if somebody looks happy
all of that is in the script it's it's a
line it's a word but there's so much
information that is presented in a john
logan script and obviously then a
director comes along and he can
interpret that
but logan doesn't just have a person
walks into a room
and that's it he'll describe what the
person's doing
his emotion very simply but effectively
one of the best pieces i ever got in my
advice in my career was ridley scott on
gladiator and it was very simple it was
right less words i'm like okay
i can do that you know and so so some of
my first drafts are
monstrously long you know and i should
probably be more disciplined but you
know why not a first draft go go and
explore you might you might discover
that that sort of ugly little you know
little little sort of troll over there
is going to be a beautiful beautiful
angel you just have to sort of let them
run around so when you handing your
first draft how many drafts is that for
you it does for you
dozens doesn't and you know and it's the
process for me of
you know here's here's like you know
i'm not much for lecturing about the
crap of screenwriting i mean if we were
talking about playwriting i could i
could speak about playwriting but you
know screenwriting sentences you heard i
just sort of fell into it and discovered
it along the way here's one piece of
advice i can give you
don't be afraid of the big line don't be
afraid to reach for the big line because
i personally have very little interest
in movies that sound like people just
sitting around a table talking that's
not my that's not the cinema that draws
me i think audiences are also drawn to
um the aspiration to the big moment
but you know you're sitting there in
your bathrobe
in chicago at seven in the morning it's
easy to type a line like
at my single unleash hell
it takes
nerve to give that line to ridley scott
you know and say yes maximus is gonna
say this line it's gonna work you know
and so so reach for the big line and
don't be afraid but the process of
working for me is is sometimes getting
the nerve up to say you know i am going
to go for the huge dramatic moment
because that's what this movie requires
or conversely i'm going to go for the
incredibly quiet subtle moment with the
last thing you would you know the last
moment you you expected those are the
things that take sort of nerve and time
and rewrite and sort of adjudication of
the the form and the piece for me i was
thinking dramatist you have to be an
incredible extrovert an incredible
introvert and you must enjoy
solitude you know the great the great uh
necessary gene for a writer
is silence and love of silence and
respect for silence i came under
gladiator when ridley scott came on and
he wanted me to come on the first thing
i did i sat down with bill nichol with
david franzoni who wrote the original
draft said let's talk about let's talk
about what you want let's talk about
what i want let's talk about sharing
back and forth and then when i left when
production started and bill nicholson
came in it was the exact same thing it
was a complete sharing so at the end of
the day when that movie came out we
three were incredibly uniformly
proud of the work we had all done and
sort of proud of each other and i
remember the oscars was unbelievable
because there was there was such a sense
of reflected glow between all three of
us and the other sort of co-writing
experience i've had which was last
samurai was the same thing with ed zwick
and marshall hirsquid it was complete
freedom and transparency back and forth
now i know that's not always the case
you know i've been i've been lucky or
i've been tenacious or i've been
stubborn or i've been stupid but i've
never had the bad experience of of just
similar being fired thrown off a movie
and having someone come in and then not
being involved or engaged what so i
think that would be would be killing
my name is maximus decimas meridius
commander of the armies of the north
general of the felix legions
loyal servant to the true emperor marcus
aurelius
father to a murdered son
husband to a murdered wife
and i will have my vengeance
in this life or the next in movies
you're looking for the visual metaphor
you're looking for for that image or
sequence of images that will suggest
what on stage would be a theatrical
effect or perhaps a line of dialogue or
an exchange between characters
so when i put my sort of movie brain on
it's it's sort of the eyebrow rays and
you're thinking about all right so the
character's feeling this
what am i showing what are we seeing
that reflecting or conversely in some
way in contradiction to that sweeney
todd's a great example because
everything that tim and and and dante
did in building that world is a very
unified world so at every moment you
think you're in sweeney todd's psyche
there's no mo there's only the one
moment of blue sky which is clearly mrs
lovett's fantasy so you know of all my
movies i think that's the most um it's
one of the ones of which i'm most proud
of my part but it's also
one of the most true to the idea that
a movie can sometimes function very well
within the
individual sort of nuances and psyches
of its protagonists i think lawrence
arabia is another movie that that does
that i think psycho does that as well
how about a shave
is it
this
[Music]
yes
[Music]
when they leave you
[Music]
i mean the thing about john logan is
incredibly versatile i mean
from bond to star trek from rango to
shakespeare
but there's
you know it doesn't matter if it's an
animated chameleon
or
a gladiator he just gets the emotion he
gets the characters he gets the detail
and he gets the drama i mean maybe
that's because he comes from theater but
he kind of understands
that there should be emotion there
should be story
how do you choose the products that you
want to work on okay is it is it
the characters is it the world is it the
story i mean what how do you select them
because clearly you must be offered lots
of things all the time
it's it's a it's a number of things it's
usually it's either
something about the story or a character
appeals to me and i think that's in my
swing circle um
you know whether it's something i'm
doing this i'm doing um patti smith
wrote a book called just kids about her
relationship with robert maplethorpe uh
and that's the next thing i'm doing
patty and i were sort of collaborating
on it together there was something about
that relationship when i read that book
that deeply moved me and i said that's a
story i want to tell you know um or it
can be
a character that appeals to me i mean i
mean the aviators i was i looked at
howard hughes and i said that's an
amazingly complex character i could turn
that character for years because these
big movies take years and you have to be
if you're not if you if you lose
interest in your protagonist you're
so it's like i'm drawn to those
characters who i don't understand who i
find interesting
and as much so the people i'm working
with it's my collaborators it's you know
who's the director who are the stars
what's the studio who's the executives
are the people that are going to make
this a challenging and rewarding
experience for me
and in the process of something like uh
the aviator for example where i
developed that with with uh michael mann
for years and we discussed it and i did
outlines i did research and we discussed
who howard hughes is what the shape of
the movie is how much of his life to you
know while i was doing the research um
it was a daily uh you know a daily
engagement with a filmmaker given cues
this kind of colorful
life shall we say uh why did you choose
that period and how did you kind of
focus on that people what was that yeah
something that came before the research
that you or no no no it was it was this
is this is yeah this is a very good
example of how sort of at least my
process works which
so leonardo dicaprio called michael
manzo that i i heard i read this howard
hughes book it's really interesting why
don't we do a howard hughes movie so
michael mann is a director admired very
much and we've been trying to find
something to do to be discussed very
things can mean said how about howard
hughes from the art dicaprio and i said
yes instantly in the room i knew exactly
i had to do that movie because i knew
enough about hughes to know there was a
story there
and my next year became figuring out
what that story was for me and if you
were to hand
howard hughes's life to um you know bill
nicholson or charlie kaufman or bill
condon you know eric roth you'd get a
completely different movie because every
artist is going to approach it from a
different perspective
so i started reading all this all the
biographies about hughes of which
they are legion you know and i just read
them all and then things began to appeal
to me you know early movies began to
appeal to me and particularly aviation
began to appeal to me as as a framework
because there's something about
um
hugh's response to aviation that was
psychologically motivated about being in
an antiseptic safe environment at 30 000
feet that i found very compelling as a
way for me to understand his germ phobia
so
it's sort of all these things sort of
came together and i realized it was it
was a movie about planes it was a movie
about aviation
for me and hughes as an engineer not
huge as a movie maker not hughes as an
obsessive compulsive not used as a lover
not hughes as a famous paranoic or rake
loose it was he as an engineer engineer
and man who wanted to fly
but
his germ phobia kept him on the ground i
thought well there's a character being
torn in half and that's really
interesting to me as as a dramatist the
thing about howard hughes is that the
sort of germaphobia that he had that
he's infamous for and logan put a little
scene that right at the beginning of the
movie where his mother is bathing him as
a child and she kind of mentions being
dirty and then all the way through the
film he logan just drops these little
kind of moments nothing kind of drawn
attention to the fact that scream kind
of germs germs germs but he just has
these little things these little seeds
that he puts through i think one of my
favorite scenes is is the scene where
kate hepburn and howard hughes meet and
they go play golf and you just think
well it's a first date scene how do you
write a first date scene why is that
interesting because those personalities
should never be on the same golf course
muscles in the same movie so to get to
play with her hyperprolix vocabulary and
learning and his sort of monotone half
death
autism
was was challenging very fulfilling uh
fulfilling to write but you know i could
say the same thing of of being able to
write patrick stewart sitting in the you
know the command chair of the enterprise
or or
you know
russell crowe and gladiator there's been
there's been many great moments that
i've been i've been proud to be uh
associated with i keep healthy i take
seven showers a day to keep clean also
because i'm what's so vogely referred to
as outdoorsy well i'm not outdoorsy i'm
athletic i sweat
there it is now we both know the sort of
truth i sweat and you're deaf
probably a fine pair of misfits
if you're dealing with
marcus aurelius from from gladiator or
howard hughes from from the aviator or
orson welles market 281 what i always
say is is this isn't this isn't life
this is biography this is in fact this
is fiction this is drama this is
make-believe this is fantasy i'm not a
historian this is not reportage it's
drama you know the same way you know the
approach to t.e lawrence alluring syria
libya is is a work of drama and no
lawrence certainly didn't look like like
peter o'toole and these weren't the
exact events the direct order i do feel
it's important to be true in some way to
the spirit
of the character you're trying to
portray
um but not the letter and i would i
would feel
personally
it would be an act of bad faith
to in any way take a character and break
it for for dramatic ends i think i think
you can bend it to a certain degree
within the limits of of probity but if
you break it you you would feel i've
done that a few times and it feel i will
feel awful about it
yeah you've got tom cruise you've got
johnny depp you've got russell crowe
you've got leonardo dicaprio actors who
bring lots to
to their performance in the role can you
talk a little bit about sort of each of
those and working with them and how they
yeah i mean it because because again my
experience is um
as a playwright you know i'm used to
talking to actors it's what you know
playwrights talk to actors all the time
there isn't you know because the the the
director as we know it in theater was
only an adventure of the 19th century
and there's a very new conceit
um there's no sense of of divinity
around the director in the theater nor
do i consider uh there to be divinity
around the idea of a director on a movie
set
not a lot of writers necessarily feel
that but that's just it's my experience
and what i feel so i'm very comfortable
talking to directors and very
comfortable talking to actors part of my
job as a playwright as a drama as a
screenwriter is to help is to he is to
hear the language and engage because
finally the words on the page are the
words on the page and boy heavens i'm
proud of them but they only live when
they're spoken either on stage or
they're spoken into into a camera and
they're recorded so it it behooves me to
be engaged to that process and i orally
need to hear it i need to hear the words
you know out loud i need to hear them
coming
from the actors to understand the
rhythms the cadences of the language and
what i will say to actors any actor is
look this doesn't sound right coming out
of your mouth let's talk about it are
there too many syllables are there not
enough is the ellipses in the wrong
place is the punctuation confusing you
do not like the semicolon let's find a
way to make it work together because i'm
a great believer in jerome robin's
single rule of the theater
which is does it work it is imperative
to hear the material out loud imperative
and coming from the theater it's just
what you're used to to you you know the
oral life of the piece is vitally
important and it's frequently
the aspect that's given the least
attention in filmmaking is the sound of
the words and the dialogue and the
rhythms of the speech uh and it's really
it's really very important to me coming
coming from a theater background and
loving sort of prosody and poetry and
literature as much as i do how the words
sound how the actors say the sound is
very important so what i always say to
actors is look if this doesn't come out
of your mouth for a certain reason if
it's not working for you let's discuss
it and find something that works because
it's like jerome robbins great rule of
theater and there's only one does it
work
it's not about my ego it's not about
johnny depp's ego it's about are we
making the right movie are we making the
best possible movie we can so so the
give and take with actors is to me a
thrilling part of the process because
it's it's where the words and the
language start coming coming alive
that's why i wish more film sets more
films would budget uh rehearsals
which is which is not usually budgeted
uh and so you're lucky if you get a
table read so the poor screenwriter is
like desperately trying to listen and
take notes the one time he gets to hear
it out loud to make
suggestions in the oral life of his work
uh which is why like theater directors
like sam mendes you know they understand
that so for bond for example we're doing
two solid weeks of rehearsal which
believe me is unheard of you know to get
into the room with me with sam with the
actors and work the scenes so when we
get on the set we know what we're trying
to sort of communicate with them
you've talked about your love of
shakespeare um
how did how did that project come about
and corey elena's came because of my my
absolute sort of besotted love of
shakespeare and i've always loved
shakespeare i've always wanted to sort
of get into and do a film adaptation
because i have been
i've been dissatisfied with some i've
been elated in others and i thought i
wanted like like every artist to have a
chance at it and i've always thought
corey lenas was the one it's it's an
unloved play that i love with it with a
central character as as dark and thorny
and ugly as all the central characters
i've ever written about you know those
titanic dark people
and i never thought anyone in the world
would be interested in this until brian
cibrell said well you know
someone else likes corey elaine this is
a movie that's ray finds i said shut up
so um so rafe was coming to la where i
lived at the time
and i went to his hotel i met him for
the first time and we started talking
about corey lanez and i realized
10 seconds in we saw the same movie
which is modern upsetting provocative
and
the purpose of which would make the
audience feel exactly like they did
after a production of the play a play we
both loved uh and i realized rafe was a
filmmaker he wasn't an actor wanting to
do a vanity project um so we committed
to doing it there's no studio there was
no money we just committed to doing it
so we spent weeks just talking about the
script talking about we we had the play
he sort of acted it out kind of all of
it which was fun uh you know we're
speeches or a disaster a speech and we
started shaping it in a modern context
we knew we wanted urban warfare we knew
we wanted sort of the modern
political machinery to be reflected we
had no idea where we're going to film
what it was going to look like
and so i wrote a screenplay which was an
adaptation of of the play and you know
every word of it is shakespeare it's
been moved around characters have been
eliminated characters have been
conjoined uh uh characters die who don't
die in the play you know we we were
muscular in our adaptation but truly i
believe it is a fantastic representation
of shakespeare's play is our version of
it and we cobbled the money together
from a million sources it was the
hardest
setting up of a movie i've ever been
involved with and therefore the most
rewarding we made it for no money in
serbia
and it is a completely pure vision
of what we wanted to create
the good senators must be visited from
whom i have received not only greetings
but with the
change of honors
i have lived to see inherited
my very wishes
and the buildings of my fancy
only there's one thing wanting
which i doubt not
but our room will
cast upon thee
good mother
i'd rather be their servant in my way
than sway with them in theirs
you know i i started writing screenplays
because i love movies you know i didn't
grow up in the theater i grew up in
movies and you know i you know the the
stories that shaped my life growing up
were were gangadin they were notorious
you know and the storytellers who shaped
my life you know weren't ibsen and
chekhov
they were howard hawks and alfred
hitchcock you know and carol reed and i
just
always loved the power of of cinema of
movies and and i wanted to be a part of
it um i never thought i would be i was
so happy in the theater i was so content
being a theater mouse and still am most
content and most happy in the world of
theater and rehearsal rooms
but films offer you something you know
they offer you
the sweep and the close-up
and to get to be part of a continuum
that includes those artists who inspired
you when you were four when you were
five you know before you knew from
aristotle before you knew from tony
kushner you knew from dorothy and the
wizard of oz you knew from sean connery
and the the the aston martin and
goldfinger you know they they were so a
part of your dna of all of our dnas that
i think i was just pulled to be part of
that story as well
[Music]
[Music]
you